[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz
präsentiert von amag von vier paaren
handeln diese geschichten von menschen
die heiraten und das leben miteinander
teilen wollen
von fragen wieso sich menschen
ineinander verlieben und wo die liebe
hinfällt ist es weiß ich gleich und
gleich gern gefällt wie es das eine
sprichwort sagt oder weil sich
gegensätze gerne anziehen wie ein
anderes behauptet oder weil es für beide
vorteile bringt
das ist die liebe noch einmal so gut
meint mit dem 77 jährigen christian
reich hätte er sich nicht träumen lassen
nicht dass er ohne erfahrung wäre mit
frauen aus der karibik aber diesmal sei
alles anders
ja bei nidda sei die liebe seines lebens
in der letzten sendung konnte christian
reich in punta cana endlich seine pin
wieder in die arme schließen
aldiana novakovic uns reden petkovic
oben für ihre serbisch-orthodoxe
traumhochzeit christian hilfiger bestand
die modeschau für braut und brautmutter
mit bravour so dass sich manuela egger
getrost ihren junggesellenabschied
wittmann konnte und andrea buchecker
besuch der zusammen mit uli bärtschi und
dessen sohn eine viehschau christian
reich ist nicht nur in der
dominikanischen republik angekommen
sondern gewissermaßen im siebenten
himmel
und er stellt fest dass bmw das ohne
jeffrey und kruse seit seinem letzten
besuch wieder ein stück größer geworden
sind der schweizer hat für seine liebe
mit einigen tausend franken den kauf und
den umbau des hauses finanziert
bienvenido dankt es ihm bei jedem besuch
von neuem
zum beispiel mit einer überraschung im
schlafzimmer
so schön
warum warum warum bin ich dabei nein
[Gelächter]
wieso diese foto haag manuelle da hat
auch christian reich und bienvenido dill
kamen diese liebesgeschichte sorgt in
den schweizer amtsstuben immer noch für
stern rund sind bei einem der letzten
besucher hier in puerto plata führte
christian bmw nieder auf standesamt
obwohl er von seiner letzten frau noch
gar nicht rechtskräftig geschieden war
das hat die situation nicht gerade
vereinfacht
aldiana novakovic hat ihre schwester
sandra gebeten sie zum chor für zu
begleiten
sandra soll sie bei der hochzeit frisur
beraten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
natürlich ist alles was ich nicht weiß
und fehlt damit seinem kapitän
ich will jetzt doch das so schwierig es
ist noch immer schwierig das entscheide
ich finde das wirklich perfekt ist sehr
unschlüssig
es stellt sich vermeiden kann und weiß
was schön ist sagt ich habe ich nur
schwierigkeiten mich festlege je näher
der hochzeitstermin rückt desto mehr
nimmt aldiana die planung der details in
die hand
der discounter aldi hanna ist wie ihr
zukünftiger mann in der schweiz
aufgewachsen
beide haben sie aber serbische wurzeln
internationalität somit andere glauben
christian hilfiger arbeitet seit vielen
jahren als landschaftsgärtner der 33
jährige liebt seine arbeit
ein drehbuch zu können 1 machten
bruchstücken angenommen
christian ist seit seiner geburt
gehörlos wie auch sein bruder und auch
seine freundin manuela ecker kam
gehörlos zur welt
manuela arbeitet in zofingen unweit von
christian entfernt in einem
pharmaunternehmen
[Musik]
als sie sich dazu entschloss von ihrer
heimat bayern in die schweiz zu ziehen
und sie dieser stelle als laborantin
[Gelächter]
in wettingen im kanton aargau wo aldiana
aufgewachsen ist wurden mittels latina
und jüngere schwester angela sehen wie
die frisur und das hochzeitskleid
zueinander passen und ich möchte das
land verliebt und dennoch möglich seite
definitiv denn schließlich soll es räten
das kleid nicht vor dem großen tag zu
sehen bekommen
[Gelächter]
das ist schon noch die befehle
wow ja wunderschön wunderschön andrea
buchecker und der landwehr to repair sie
haben vor ein paar wochen ihre
hochzeitsringe ausgesucht
[Musik]
sie springen
der familie ist schöner wenn der dicke
teil vorder und so wird nur der thw ist
sein einsatz fand ich dass die zwei
verschiedene buchstaben oder die zwei
verschiedene farben und lebt bis robust
aber nicht zu groß natürlich noch ein
bisschen sind ja was ist sehr tanzbar
achse hegen bisher übrigens nicht gold
ist also sehr schnell wo man denn alles
ist natürlich doppelt alle priester und
diese person dreh mit dem format der
hochstand alle welt sehen mit dem fach
und ringkampf mit 230 franken will man
jetzt einfach die brüder wie ist wo wir
verlieren dann weiß ich wo vom aus stoff
in thüringen und wünschen er mehr auto
und der in die sex wenn jetzt sehr
wichtig die 215 haben pflicht damit eine
neue mode baustellen wurden mit wem 8
und wenn die usb sticks und verleitet
die diabolos und ihrer regierung muss
also mit einem fahndungs hochzog und zu
genießen steht ja müssen
seit sechs jahren kommt christian wann
immer möglich in die dominikanische
republik und auch wenn es sein innigster
wunsch ist dass wir ihn wieder
irgendwann die erlaubnis erhält zu ihm
in die schweiz zu reisen
so sieht es eine eigene zukunft hier bei
ihr ist wichtig sich nach mir meine
kritiker die schmeckt dass man sich
kritik auch dass man sehr tolerantes sie
mit mehr und die vor allem mit dass mein
herz angriffen steckt mehr hand sehr
viel grieche die meinigen und kirche die
absicht die hand x-mal nächtelang also
stundenlang nach dem motto miteinander
diskutiert über das leben und über alles
und hat einfach gepasst das ist so schön
dass ich genau davon ich erwarte dass
einfach passt und dass man einfach immer
kritisch
in diesen tagen jedoch ist sie nicht da
sondern eher bei ihr um sie einmal mehr
auch finanziell ein wenig zu
unterstützen
[Gelächter]
ich alles sicher ist alles gut kann ja
ich besuche ich bin 77 und ich weiß dass
milliardär
also was sehe ich ganz spielt überhaupt
keine rolle mehr ich bin nur sehr sehr
unglücklich da schlackern
ich weiß dass ich nicht werden
ein altersheim graf will darf keine
liebe ist mein mann meine große liebe
in der regie in sachen will ist
christian hilfiger aufgewachsen seine
mutter erinnert sich gerne an diese zeit
und an diese teddybären die damals für
christian und seinen ebenfalls
gehörlosen bruder eine wichtige rolle
spielten
wenn sie nicht getraut häuser bis frage
heiße dpa vor
und hey als der bartec direkt und das
ist zwar verlangsamen oder bello dass
nahrung war otto auf dem fenstersims
dass ich irgendwie mit viereinhalb
jahren waren christian und sein bruder
uhr lieder nur noch am wochenende zu
hause
er hat es ja um kontakte und kontakte
prognosen audio isolieren und das ist
wichtig sprache dass sie die
sprachlehrer und da kann man nicht
früher klima das hat mir erzählt mit der
mauer berliner kaiser die kölner nicht
dass die die auch gar nicht würde wäre
retten wenn man bei man mitmacht
hallo
für lisa hilfiger war bald klar dass
christian mit manuela sein glück
gefunden hat
fast zur selben zeit in basel besonderen
tag von ihm brüder vor ihrem freund
jürgen vetter gemacht und nach unsere
gute jungs hätten weil es nach wie vor
vor gar nicht er weiß auch nicht wie das
ganze
wer weiß was als nächstes passiert und
wir können genau in diese ungewissheit
studio aus diesem tag 30
[Musik]
aber das ist noch die alte freunde
wiederzusehen
[Gelächter]
alles was räten zum voraus wusste war
dass er einen ausweis mitzunehmen habe
die reise geht nach deutschland
[Musik]
bewegende worte
[Applaus]
die rücklichter
[Musik]
in nossen im kanton st gallen ist das
stück wie der bärtschis bezugsbereit
stolz übergibt der landwirt und gelernte
schreiner seinen eltern das neue zuhause
hat keine ahnung der 2 die steine dann
später mit dem computer elite und
deutsch wahlprogramm verspricht jetzt
die spärlichen zwei tribünen bin ich
bitte nochmals schwierigkeiten wenn wir
nicht viel wasser blut hätten nach licht
rückt und du sauber aber irgendwer was
produkt hätte mal gedruckt und
deutschland jedes für sich
die knie spüre die rolle spielen
unglaublich begeistert gezeigt nun
endlich so plötzlich wünscht williams
endet alles ändert oder exotisch und
automobilclubs einzusehen oder hat
braucht das album klingt maschine bricht
und deutschen jahr überhaupt noch eine
undankbare werkstoffe herrschaft war
eine vom alten karten lebst du das
außerdem haben die autoschlüssel vier
stück das uhr ließ eltern ihre freude an
daheim auf ganz unterschiedliche art
zeigen davon kriegt uhr ließ zukünftige
frau wenig mit andrea buchecker arbeitet
als projektmanagerin an der hochschule
st gallen für studierende eines
weiterbildungslehrgang der hsg hat sie
eine studienreise nach peking
organisiert für sie ist es eine rückkehr
in das land in dem sie bereits einmal
für zwei jahre gearbeitet und gelebt hat
die abschaffung des gerichtsjahres der
kombination zwischen andrea will ihren
beruf in nächster zukunft nicht ganz
aufgeben
zugunsten von kindern will sie aber
kürzer treten
mit dem normalerweise und auch nicht bei
den selben ort suchen frieden
einzusetzen inhaltlicher verzeichnet
[Musik]
noch in den 90er jahren galt an jeder
schule die christian und sein bruder uli
besuchten ein eigentliches verbot für
gebärdensprache
das heißt ich ganz gern
wir verstehen halt manchmal nicht was ja
für den vater peter hilfinger war es
anfangs nicht leicht zu akzeptieren dass
beide söhne gehörlos sind mit dem
schrecken und auch sie mit dem enkel der
inschrift dass ich nicht
die liebe davon sind bieten wir nieder
und christian überzeugt die liebe vermag
jedes sprachliche hindernisse zu
überwinden
und wenn die liebe auch noch geschickte
hände hat dann kommt es auf die
einzelnen worte nicht mehr an
[Musik]
sid die sakrale und gemerkt wie wichtig
dass er sich das gut zusammen aber hat
mit mit ihren mit der familie und das
ich für mich schon der himmel auf erden
ein paar tage später im toggenburg
andrea ist zurück aus peking heute will
andrea melken lernen sie befürchtet dass
sie am hochzeitsfest irland
wirtschaftliches geschick beweisen muss
dass sie zur vollzeit bäuerin wird
glaubt sie hingegen nicht hier wird
einfach die zukunft auch eine berufung
du musst mit befähigung heirate und dann
aber nur wenn sie denn es besteht bei
uns richtig chor kostenschub
erschwinglich für den graf wie lange es
gab musik events laufen ist die zwei
fahren
die türen vorhanden europa hat zu machen
und ohne stress und dann nach vorne
schön links rechts links rechts
aber ich glaube dir kalt
weiter steht 2 d-moll bwv definieren
das sind einfach wie traum sprich wo man
kann
lerby entwickelt sich erst mit der opel
führung durch die gute wie auch
schlechte zeiten wenn es ein gutes oder
schlechtes bbb stevens vertraute auf
drei zähler beim renault tisch und da
geht einer kraft stellt dem auf und da
kann sie nicht erkennen erhöht und seine
eliten
petkovic freunde haben sich für den
junggesellenabschied ein programm
ausgedacht das ganz nach seinem
geschmack ist
bräutigam hin oder her auf der
rennstrecke können die freunde kein
pardon keinem käme es auch nur in den
sehnen der hauptperson des tages den
vortritt zu lassen
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit in kilchberg am
zürichsee hinter aldi hannes rücken
haben ihre schwestern und ein paar
freundinnen auch für sie einen
polterabend organisiert
was aldiana an diesem abend noch erleben
wird darüber geben beim genauen hinsehen
die verschiedenen accessoires einen
hinweis einiges besser glaubt sie jedoch
übertretens programm im bild zu sein
[Musik]
ich musste nicht nur die mode für mich
zum sieg hat es nicht gereicht
ausgezeichnet wird er heute aber
trotzdem wenn christian an die
bevorstehende hochzeit denkt dann
erhellt sich üblicherweise sein gesicht
außer beim gedanken an den hochzeitstanz
der beispiele die einmal tun
[Musik]
doch christian wäre nicht christian wenn
er sich den wahren herausforderungen im
leben eines mannes nicht stellen würde
[Musik]
diese typisch
frisch geduscht nach dem kampf auf der
go kart bahn trifft redners
männergesellschaft in freiburg im
breisgau ein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die stadt darf man sich nicht gewünscht
noch mal was heißt bei uns vorher seit
die türkei treten setzt seinen ganzen
charme ein als er mit passantinnen um
einen kleinen umtrunk spielt wenn ich
hier aber ist unentschieden
was liegt egal da ich nicht
danke für alles zusammen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der abend ist fortgeschritten als für
aldiana in kirchberg ein weiterer
programmpunkt ansteht
doch ihre gedanken sind in diesem moment
weiß reden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in einem striplokal ist räten zu dieser
zeit tatsächlich nicht und doch sind
aldiana befürchtungen nicht ganz
unbegründet lebensfreunde haben es sich
nicht nehmen lassen ihm zu ehren eine
art künstlerische darbietung zu
organisieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch vor geschlechterspezifischen
vorverurteilungen sei gewarnt
spät abends wird auch aldiana auf die
bühne gebeten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so spielen sich da und dort ganz
ähnliche szenen ab egal ob sich die
gegensätze an oder ausziehen
[Musik]
christian macht fortschritte und da hat
noch ein paar wochen zeit um den
hochzeitstanz zu üben
[Musik]
doch obwohl es schon ganz flott
ausschaut so richtig zufrieden ist er
nicht mit sich
dann beginnt das nächste woche macht
christian nägel mit köpfen und führt
seine manuela auf standesamt
[Musik]
auch an dianas uns redens familien
treffen sich zur zivilen hochzeit
während andrea und uri nach einem
geeigneten lokal für ihren hochzeits
apéro suchen in der dominikanischen
republik fühlt sich christian der senior
nochmals jung wie ein teenager dank
bienvenido
zeichen der liebe heute in einer woche
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz mit
glück mit ul versicherungen blutgeld
seit 20 jahren für sie da